Phil briefed us right now and breathe
the Admiral on where we are with our
Atlantic agreement if we're getting
finished with a Pacific agreement is
there going to be a corresponding
agreement well Mike Froman the US trade
ambassador pretty much never gets a
holiday Mike right at Tom right after he
announces agreement the US trade
representatives office noted that they
were coming out again and they would be
meeting on the t tip all ministers would
be meeting on T tip this has a lot more
work to do and I think part of the
reason was the focus from the United
States almost entirely was on the
Pacific Rim trade pact over the last
couple years this was kind of in the
backseat but I do think the focus will
shift to this in a big way I don't think
Tom when you talk to administration
officials there's a lot of confidence
that this will get done in the next 15
months there's going to need there's
going to need to be a lot of effort
expended on capitol hill in the US
domestically to pass trade the Pacific
trade agreement but I do think they want
to lay the groundwork so the next
administration can come in pick up the
ball and get this done and a quick
fashion yeah you see it body with with
secretary Clinton's comments yeah
exactly can we pull it ago we know that
yep and I want to ask Phil as well so
today we're gonna learn some more
details on how Hillary Clinton is going
to come out chastising Wall Street
really and her advisor is Barney Frank
it turns out he's one of the advisors
Gary Gensler obviously the former
chairman of the CFTC is also one of the
senior people that were involved in this
plan according to a hill hillary clinton
ain't i spoke to last night the plans
got multiple elements but there's two
really that i think are going to be
interesting for wall street one is she's
looking a transaction tax on high
frequency trading I the bulk
cancellation orders and the others she's
trying to tighten up the Volcker Rule
guys obviously from a 2010 law those
will be the two key elements phil
mattingly thank you so much gocubs it'll
be fun to watch Phil Mattingly helping
on from Washington